in the last video we saw how a matrix
and figuring out its inverse can be used
to solve a system of equations and we
did a two by two and in the future we'll
do three by threes we won't do four by
fours because those take too long but
you'll see it applies to kind of an n by
n matrix and that is probably the
application of matrices that you learn
if you learn this in your algebra 2
class or your algebra 1 class
and then you often wonder why even do
the whole matrix thing now i will show
you another
application of matrices that actually
you'll you're more likely to see in your
linear algebra class when you take it in
college
but but the really neat thing here is to
show i think this will really hit the
point home that
the matrix representation is just one
way of representing multiple types of
problems and what's really cool is that
if different problems can be represented
the same way it kind of tells you that
the same problem that's called an
isomorphism in math that if if you can
reduce one problem into another problem
then all the work you did with one of
them applies to the other but anyway
let's so let's figure out a new way that
matrix matrices can be used so i'm going
to
draw some vectors let's say i have the
vector
let's call this vector a
let's say i have vector a
and it equals and i'm going to just
write this as a column vector and you
know all of this this is just convention
these are just human invented things i
could have written this diagonally i
could written this however but if i say
vector a
is
3 comma
negative 6 not comma but you know 3
negative 6
and i view this as the x component of
the vector and this is equal to the y
component of the vector and then i have
vector b
vector
b
vector b
is equal to
vector b i have is equal to
let me make sure i get this 2
comma 6
and i want to know
i want to know
is there some combinations of vector a
and b where you know i could say you
know i don't know 5 times vector a plus
three times vector b or ten times vector
a minus six times vector b some
combination of vector a and b where i
can get vector c
where i i can get vector c and vector c
is
the vector
is the vector
7 6. so let me see if i can visually
draw this problem so let me draw the
coordinate axes
let's see this one three comma negative
six that will be in quark all these are
both in the first coordinates so i just
want to figure out what i how much i
need to how much of the axes i need to
draw so let's see
so if this is the y let me do a
different color
i do different color
that's my y-axis i'm not doing drawing
the second or third quadrants because i
don't think our vectors show up there
and then this is
this is the x-axis
let me draw each of these vectors
so first i'll do vector a
vector a that's three comma negative six
so
one
two
three and then negative six
one
two
three
four
five six so it's
there
so if i wanted to draw it as a vector
visually start at the origin
and it doesn't have to start at the
origin like that i'm just choosing to
you can you can move around a vector it
just has to have the same orientation
and the same magnitude
all right so that is vector
a
that's vector a for the green now let me
do in magenta i'll do vector b
that is 2 comma 6
1 2
5 6. so 2 comma
6. so 2
comma
6 is right over there
and that's vector b
vector b
it'll look like this
it's vector b
and let me do vector write down vector a
down there
that's vector a
and i want to take some combination of
vectors a and b and add them up and get
vector c so what does vector c look like
it's 7 comma
let me do that in purple so one two
three
four
five
six seven comma six
so seven comma six is right over there
that's vector c
vector c is looks like that
vector c
let me oh yeah i want to draw it like
that
and that's vector
c
so what is the original problem i said i
said i want to add some multiple of
vector a to some multiple of vector b
and get vector c and i want to see what
those multiples are so let's say the
multiple that i multiply times vector a
is x and the multiple of vector b is y
so i essentially want to say
that
let me do it in another neutral color
that vector a
x
right that's how much of vector a i'm
contributing
plus vector b
y
that's how much of vector b i'm
contributing is equal to
vector
c
and you know maybe i can't maybe there's
no
combinations of vector a and b when you
add them together equal vector c but
let's see if we can solve this
so how do we solve so let's let's expand
out vectors a and b vector a is what 3
comma negative 6. so this is
vector a we could write as
minus 6
times x
right that just tells us how much vector
a we're contributing plus vector b which
is two comma six
which is two comma six
and then y is how much vector b we're
contributing and that is equal to
seven comma 6 vector c
now this right here this
problem can be rewritten just based on
how we've defined matrix multiplication
et cetera et cetera as this
as
minus 6
times
x y
is equal to
6.
now how does that work out well think
about how matrix multiplication works
out the way we learned matrix
multiplication we said oh you know
3 three times
three times x
plus two times y
is equal to seven right
three times x plus two times y is equal
to seven that's how we learn matrix
multiplication but that's the same thing
here 3 times x
plus 2 times y is going to be equal to
7. right these x and y here are just
scalar numbers right so 3 times x plus 2
times y equals 7 and then matrix
multiplication here minus 6 times x plus
6 times y is equal to 6 that's just
traditional matrix multiplication that
we learned several videos ago that's the
same thing here minus 6x plus 6y is
equal to 6. these are just these x's and
y's are just
numbers they're just scalar numbers
they're not vectors or anything so we
just we just multiply them times both of
these numbers
so hopefully you see that this problem
is the exact same thing as this problem
and you've maybe had an aha moment now
if you've watched the previous video
because this matrix this matrix
also represented the problem well where
do we find the intersection of two lines
where the two lines and i'm just going
to do it on the side here you know the
intersection of the two lines three x
plus two y is equal to 7
and
minus
x plus 6y is equal to 6. and so you know
i had drawn two lines and we said oh
what's the point of intersection et
cetera et cetera and it was represented
by this problem but here we have
i won't say a completely different
problem because we're learning they're
actually very similar but here i'm doing
a problem of i'm trying to find what
combination of the matrices a and b
add up to the matrix c but it got
reduced to the same matrix
representation and so we can solve this
with the same exact way we solved this
problem
if we call this the matrix a let's
figure out a inverse
so we get a inverse let me say a inverse
is equal to what it equals 1 over the
determinant of a
the determinant of a is 3 times 6 18
minus
minus 12 so that's 18 plus 12 which is 1
over 30.
and we did this in the previous video
you swap these two numbers so you get 6
and 3
and then you make these two negatives so
you get 6 and minus 2.
that's a inverse and now to solve for x
and y we can multiply both sides of this
equation by a inverse if you multiply a
inverse times a it can't this cancels
out so you get
you get
x comma y
is equal to a inverse times this
so it's equal to 1 over 30
times 6 minus 2 6 3
times 7 6 and remember with matrices the
order that you multiply matters so on
this side we multiplied a inverse on
this side of the equation so we have to
do a inverse on the left side
on this side of this equation so that's
why i did it here if we did it the other
way
all bets are off
so what does this equal
this is equal to 1 over 30
times
and we do this in the previous problem 6
times 7 is 42
minus 12 30
6 times 742 plus 18 60
so that equals
2.
so what does this tell us this tells us
that if we have 1 times vector a
plus 2 times vector b right 1 times this
is 1
and 2 times vector b so 1 times vector a
plus 2 times vector b is equal to vector
c and let's confirm that visually so 1
times vector a well that's vector a
right there so if we add two vector b's
to it we should get vector c so let's
see if we can do that
so if we just shift vector b over this
way well vector b
let's see vector b is over 2 and up 6 so
over 2
and up 6 would get us there
so one vector b
just doing heads to tail visual method
of adding vectors
would get us there
right one two three okay
i think
no let me see
that's it let's see one
two three
and then vector b it goes over two more
two more
and then
so it'll get us an up six it's like that
so that's one vector b
and then if we add another but we want
two times vector b right we essentially
have made two vector pieces we add one
and then we add another one
i think visually you see that it does
actually
well i didn't want to do it like that i
wanted to use the line tool so it looks
neat
so yet another vector b
and there you have it
that's a vector b
so it's two times vector b so it's the
same direction as vector b but it's two
times the length so we visually showed
it we
we solved it algebraically but the real
learning and the big real discovery of
this whole video is to show you that
this matrix this the matrix
representation can represent multiple
different problems this was a uh
at you know finding the combinations of
vector problem and in the previous one
it was figure out if two lines can
intersect but but what it tells you
something is that these two problems are
connected in some deep way that you know
if we take the veneer of reality that
underlying it they are the same thing
and you know frankly that that's why
math is so interesting because
when you realize that two problems are
really the same thing it takes all of
the superficial human veneer away from
things because you know our brains are
kind of wired to perceive the world in a
certain way but it tells us that there's
some
fundamental truth independent of our
perception that that is tying all of
these different concepts together but
anyway i don't want to get all mystical
on you but if if you do see the
mysticism in math all the better but
hopefully you found that uh
pretty interesting and actually i know
i'm going over time but i think this is
kind of
you know a lot of people they take
linear algebra they learn how to do all
of the things and they say what was the
whole point of this but this is kind of
an interesting thing to to think about
you know we had this matrix a
we have this we sorry we have this
vector a and we had this vector b and we
were able to say well there's some
combinations of the vectors a and b that
when we added up we got vector c right
so an interesting question is
what are all the vectors that i could
that i could get to by adding
combinations
of vectors a and b or adding or
subtracting or you could say you know i
could multiply them by negative numbers
but either way what are all of the
vectors that i can get by taking
linear combinations of vectors a and b
and that's actually called the vector
space
spanned by the vectors a and b and we'll
we'll do more of that in in linear
algebra and here we're dealing with a
two-dimensional euclidean space we could
have had three-dimensional vectors we
could have had n-dimensional vectors so
it gets really really really abstract
but this is i think a really good um toe
dipping for for linear algebra as well
well hopefully i haven't confused or
overwhelmed you and i will see you in
the next video